another way love bombing can happen is
they will present a very overly
victimized story of their lives like
my life has been so hard my life has
been so tough and rescuers will say
oh my gosh you need a place to live come
over with me or you need a car like i
don't always use my car
covert narcissists tend to play that
game a little bit more very victimized
love bombing
and people feel like i want to rescue
them and they really do well with people
who are hyper empaths
but then what will happen is they'll
start losing a little steam you're like
okay
i'm into you and you move things too
fast narcissistic relationships
more often than not move too fast people
move in too fast they get engaged too
fast they talk about marriage too fast
they travel together too fast they move
to another city too fast
too fast and why because the narcissist
needs to get you to the point where they
can
devalue you once you agree to them they
have
believe it or not such low self-esteem
like if you want to be with me you can't
be all that is actually probably what's
happening deep inside of them
but what they have is they have you
where they need you
this podcast exists because i
love talking to people and i love going
deep the purpose is
to plant seeds of inspiration we
enter a space of vulnerability and
relatability and what you realize
is that we are so much more alike than
we are different
to quote ramdas we're all just walking
each other home
and this show is just one step i'm
danica patrick
and i'm pretty intense there's a very
special guest on the show today her name
is dr
romney she is an expert in the field of
narcissistic personality disorder and
npd narcissists narcs whatever you want
to call them
it's something that i think is a really
important topic to bring to light
because there's so much damage that's
done
with this personality disorder and this
form of abuse
and so it may be something that happened
in childhood it might be a relationship
it might be at the workplace but to
understand
truly what it is and how to deal with it
i think are incredible tools because
it's undoubtedly happening in your life
and i mean you as in like every single
person listening
has some level of exposure to narcissism
and sometimes many um it tends to be a
tends to be an attractor for people that
are empaths and very kind-hearted this
is a really really deep
conversation about all the forms of
narcissism
the uh forms of abuse of narcissism the
cycle of abuse
and and then what we can do about it
what you can do about it
i think that this is a really i think
this is a really healthy
conversation about something very
unhealthy so i hope you get a lot from
it and i hope that you're well
take care i i feel like
there's so much narcissism around and
that it's not until you have really
experienced it that you
know what to look for or know the
repercussions of it even and so
i think this is just such a good
conversation to have
because uh you know as you said like
being in racing and being in a male
dominated world
and especially competitive highly
competitive
i mean yeah i was probably all around me
and now i can look back and see it but i
couldn't see it while i was in it
because i didn't really
have that firsthand experience of what
it's like but it's
truly like it's it's it's
it's obvious once you've had the
experience so i
i just think this is such an incredible
conversation i have for people to
get some awareness so your point you
know is that a lot of people don't
understand it until it happens to them
that's really the struggle because
believe it or not even in this
modern world there's some people out
there where it hasn't happened to them
or they're
so good at justifying it that they don't
want to see
it right and so when a person who's
going through it actually turns to maybe
a friend who doesn't get it
they'll often get pushback and people
say oh you know
that's just how they are they're just
intense and
this is not about intense this is about
something so abusive that cuts you to
the core
it's an entirely different experience
and once people understand it
the only thing i've ever wanted for
people is to not blame themselves
because that's what people do in these
relationships they blame themselves and
say
maybe i'm not trying hard enough and
maybe i'm not this enough and maybe i'm
not that enough
so you're doing your part you're being
abused you decide how you want to
proceed
yeah yeah i think that a lot of it comes
down to for me that i can look at and go
i never had boundaries and so like when
you don't have boundaries
and you're a kind loving compassionate
caretaker all of a sudden you become
just like
it's just you can't see through the see
through it
so i'm curious how you got
how you evolved into this place
and speaking about narcissism like you
do did you have an experience or is this
just a progression of
your profession it's a lot of different
things i mean i initially it really
started from a very professional place
i'm
also a university professor i was doing
research on it and i was saying
why are some of the people coming into a
clinic we were working with
they are this i said this small group of
patients is taking
everybody's attention and energy and you
know so
the small group of patients was getting
90 of the nurses and the staff's
attention and everyone else who's
actually a really nice
compliant client patient they weren't
getting i'm saying gosh these people are
breaking these people down
and that led to a program of research on
this but at the same time i'm also a
psychologist in practice
and more and more people were coming in
and telling me the same story of their
marriages and also were saying
i was in therapy and i worked on
communication and they were really
nice clearly communicating people i said
oh this is what it sounds like
and once they understood narcissism
honestly sometimes in six to eight weeks
they're like okay
got it some would go and get divorced
some would set boundaries
and a lot of them stopped blaming
themselves it wasn't always that quick
sometimes it would take months or years
so there's a whole range and yeah it has
happened to me and it's ironic because
even in my own life i knew it was toxic
i knew it was unhealthy
but i probably about 10 15 years ago i
really started getting into this work
and then um and what i noticed was
there's a huge hole in the world of
mental health nobody wants to talk about
it
it kind of feels not nice like it's as
psychologists we're supposed to be warm
and fuzzy with everyone
i said i'm not i have worked with a lot
of narcissistic patients that's what's
interesting probably a third of my
practice
and so and i do great work with them but
i can see
i don't know that i want to be in a
relationship with them but i want to
help
them understand their impact on others
and they themselves are having a tough
time too but i don't care if you're
having a tough time
you don't get to take it out on other
people so it was like it was a it was a
mix of research clinical interest
and and my personal stuff and it all
came into this and then nobody cared
danica to be honest with you
they didn't care until they cared it was
really probably in the last five years
in this country things switched
the world sort of changed we became more
polarized and when that happened
this word started floating out there
much more at a public level
and then again people started listening
i think i was talking to myself for
about 10 years
before people started listening so it
was all good
so do you think that narcissism is being
revealed
more now or it's on the rise due to a
level of polarization
i don't know if it's literally on the
rise i think a little bit
things like social media the ability to
behave badly on the internet
the kinds of people we sort of idolize
in our society
really are often the noisy bullies and
we idolize people with a lot of money
and narcissistic people always have more
money and so if you say i want to be a
billionaire
in today's day and age and more often
not saying i want to be a pharmacist
so it's the people we value we don't
value a teacher who
knocks herself out to help kids who are
having trouble learning that's not our
hero
our hero is the person who has the jets
and the rockets and all this nonsense so
part of it is what we value in our
society but i think what's happening
too is that now that we i think for a
long time
people tolerated this behavior they're
like that's just someone being intense
that's just boys being boys that's just
somebody being difficult
or there's two sides to every story i
mean i've heard every rationale for this
and i've worked with people who stayed
in these marriages for 40 plus years
so they've heard all the rationales for
a long time
and they almost had to go with the
rationale if they were going to stay in
the relationship so i actually think
this pattern has always been around but
i think we found
huge ways of justifying it and now
people are saying enough you can't bully
people at work you can't this is not
okay it's actually taking a real toll
and it's the toll on people that it
takes that's very much a focus on my
work which is
if you bully people and gaslight people
and manipulate people enough you're
actually going to you're making them
sick
and that's the piece i wanted to address
i agree
is there before we get on to all that
because and
uncovering all the tactics and ways that
could be like someone could be listening
to me like oh my god that's me
because that's like i like read one that
was like the top ten i was like oh my
god
it's like a solid like one hot nut like
nine out of ten
for sure i was like oh my god i'm pretty
sure this is an a
um but um is there
a healthy i mean because you know you
say things like if you're successful if
you have the jets or if you make money
and so you know presumably i could fall
into that category to some degree so is
there
is there uh is there a healthy
um level of code of narcissism or
is there an assumed level of narcissism
to
everyone and it is truly a scale so
let's not call it narcissism and
let's call it that because i hate the
term healthy narcissism because i think
at the core of it this pattern of
narcissism
the lack of empathy the entitlement the
grandiosity
the contempt for other people the
validation seeking the superficiality
the
you know the the lashing out at other
people being arrogant and controlling
and
sensitive to criticism and hypocritical
i don't think that's ever healthy
right i do think people can become
successful without those qualities
i think it is a bit more of an exception
than a rule to be honest with you but i
absolutely think it can happen and i've
met
and worked with people who are
extraordinarily successful and deeply
empathic
and they managed to make it work often
because they had a gift like they were
very good at the thing they did
and so because of that they were able to
succeed but i think the people
who had to sort of scrap and manipulate
and work the system
that's a little bit more problematic so
i think that what some of us may have is
healthy assertiveness
um healthy uh competition so the idea
that i'm gonna compete this fair and
square i'm gonna
i'm gonna put in the best effort i've
got and i'm gonna win this race clean
and then i am going to then celebrate
the that winning and be strategic
it's the idea of that for a narcissistic
person they may not win the race clean
and then they will throw under other
people under the bus once they win are
on their way to winning
so there's a difference yeah that makes
sense so
what causes it i mean this is the very
fascinating and i mean at the end of the
day of all the work that i've done
especially in the last year like i
have realized only more and more how it
really
it's all childhood it comes from
the beginning and so what
what is it what dynamics uh
lead to a narcissistic existence and
you know emotional state or lack of
emotion
well here's where it gets tricky is that
narcissism is one of those destinations
that a person can
that different people can get through
through different pathways
and some of those pathways are more
tragic and some of those pathways are
actually almost more a little bit
not so tragic i guess is the only way i
could put it at the most tragic end of
it danica would be
thinking about somebody who actually
might have had a relatively chaotic
abusive traumatic childhood
and because of that they may not have
been able to form healthy attachments
during their early years in the absence
of those healthy attachments
they had to grow all these unhealthy
sort of patterns like a defense
against all of that vulnerability and so
they're always punching at the world
they're sort of
angry at the world and in a way if you
think of them as a small traumatized
child
we can think of why they're angry at the
world which is why sometimes
narcissism and post-traumatic stress has
a fair amount of overlap so
there's that group okay then there's a
group of people who have attachment
issues
and it wasn't frankly traumatic in the
family of origin but it might have been
a bit inconsistent the parents might
have been narcissistic themselves or
totally self-focused or all about them
and their appearances and
their lives and their stuff and their
kids were sort of almost an annoyance
and they weren't really available to
them and these are households where
emotion would have been devalued or even
shamed that so there's that pathway
which some people could even listen to
this and say you know dr romney i'd
actually argue that's a little bit
traumatic
too and i don't disagree with that but
i'm not talking about almost like the
frank physically
sexually abusive but yes this can be
traumatizing as well
but it's sort of there's a emptiness to
the childhood so you get to go on
great vacations and you know pretty
thanksgivings and all of that but
there's sort of an emptiness to it the
parents are really egocentric
and focused on themselves then we get to
the sort of what i call sort of the
performing pony kind of model of
narcissism
where people are really raised because
they're one-trick ponies they're raised
because
they're great at a sport they're great
at they're really beautiful
they're they're the kid that the parent
gets narcissistic supply from
so the parent almost invests so much in
that kid
these kids are going to perform
performing kids are just great at
something
but the kid almost gets the message we
love you because
you are so great at this not like i have
this great kid i love
and they happen to have these other
interests the parents almost overly
intrude themselves into the child's life
and the child's identity gets totally
wrapped in this thing they do
rather than who they are and they retain
that performing poniness all the way
into adulthood
they focus only on achievement and they
never learn emotion in fact these are
kids if they're in for example something
competitive
their parent will be like why'd you do
so bad what was that about
and the poor kid just wants their parent
to say that's okay like this is just a
game i love you
that sort of thing can also go into
narcissism and then there's other things
in the family like having a narcissistic
parent
in most cases it doesn't result actually
in a narcissistic child in most cases
having a narcissistic parent
results in having an anxious child but
in a subset of cases that can happen
but we're really talking about issues
around attachment around emotional
regulation
how much the child learns to regulate
their emotions the less of that they're
taught
the more likely they are to become
narcissistic
and then how narcissistically the
parents behaved you know like maybe not
the parents weren't full-on narcissists
but they were super entitled they were
you know really sort of rude and
controlling that can also raise the odds
but like i said
just as often if not more children who
grow up with that kind of parent end up
becoming more anxious
than they are to become narcissistic so
you can see there's a lot of pathways
that can get you there
and as a psychologist i can tell you
when i see the narcissistic people who
came
via the traumatic root they look a
little different
than the ones who came from where that
performing pony
the parents only cared about how things
looked but they didn't care about who
their kids were
they're different they feel different to
me as a psychologist and they probably
but i have to say for a person in a
relationship with with either of these
groups it's going to be difficult
there's no getting away from that you
had touched on this and it's a
it's a it's a question that i have um
is codependency because anxious could
maybe presumably be sort of pushed into
the codependent side is that
accurate so let's talk a little bit
about codependency because it's a tricky
term
because here's where it gets interesting
let's talk first about anxiety with
narcissism and then this thing called
codependency
a lot of people think because
narcissists are so braggy
and grandiose and look how great i am
that they think that they must be
confident and they're actually
less confident than the rest of us
because they're so braggy like you
wouldn't be bragging like if you're
great you're like
thanks so much and just what i do and i
practice and whatever
but the folks who really really have to
put on the big grandiose shows of
look at me i'm wonderful there's a deep
deep insecurity and frankly a deep
anxiety that underlies that
and the anxiety is very much about
they're going to
really some and it's not like it's
conscious like at a deep level there's
the sense of i'm not perfect
somebody's going to see i'm not perfect
i'm going to get rejected
and worse i'm going to be shamed and
that constant fear of that means that
the minute somebody critiques them
they completely lose their minds they go
completely rageful
they throw a huge tantrum everyone
either is scared of them or
what the heck and then they feel ashamed
of that reaction
and then that makes them mad again and
that's why you're constantly in these
sort of anger cycles
with narcissistic people so that's where
the anxiety piece is on the narcissism
side
a lot of people who end up in
relationships with narcissistic people
have the tendency to call themselves
codependent and i always say to them put
the brakes on
because i'm always a little afraid of
that label because what codependency
implies is also a i want to say a
deficit but like a
a not like a a vulnerability
and then not getting it like a
codependent person is almost
you know completely unaware clueless
call it what you will
in my work in narcissistic abuse i would
i wouldn't disagree that there's a
subset of people who might fall more
into this sort of codependent
i have to prove myself for love i have
to earn love
i'm going to stay with the broken person
and rescue them i do get my self-esteem
out of how well my partner's doing i
don't disagree there's a subset
but i have to say danica a lot of people
i've worked with
who wrote themselves off as codependents
and then i just basically did some basic
education on narcissistic abuse and said
are you telling me this person is not
going to change i said honey i'm telling
you this person is not going to change
and i said that is all i needed to hear
and they really do kind of pop out of it
either they say
i'm just going to cultivate a life
outside of this relationship or i'm
getting out
to me that doesn't feel like
codependency to me that feels like a
lack of knowledge
they just didn't know i think some
people even
after they know they still keep going in
like a moth flying into a flame
that would feel more like the
codependency piece is there
is the original wound of
i'm sort of making i'm giving you my
words or my interpretation
but being uh essentially abandonment of
emotion
is is is the is that core wound the same
for a narcissist as a codependent but
the reactions are different
it's possible you know it's an
interesting area because like i said
codependency is sort of a
it's sort of a we know probably a little
bit more about narcissism than we do
about codependency and it's not
something we actually formally recognize
in kind of the world of psychology if
anything codependency might be
viewed as more of a dependent
personality cell but like i said
once the person with the dependent
personality style style gets the
playbook they're like
oh okay i get this now thanks
do i think the core wound it may be
quite similar because what we often
forget
is that people who are narcissistic are
really afraid of abandonment
it's a big thing for them and they get
really rageful when they think it's
coming up
and they get really scared that it might
come up because it's a rejection of them
which is already bringing up all that
shame a person who is in a
sort of would be classified under the
sort of umbrella of codependency
you know would also have that same fear
of sort of losing the identity they get
through sort of being in this in this
very unhealthy relationship
codependent people when they're in
unhealthy relationships
it almost gives them something to do and
a place to drive like i said a sense of
self
if they were in a healthy relationship
it would almost feel
boring you know like what do i do with
myself you're helping and you're being
nice and you're being empathic and
you're encouraging me
like it's as though when we're looking
at what are called codependents
sometimes it's also called trauma bonded
though they're a little bit different
it's this you keep having the same
arguments over and over again
it's almost like it's relaxing even
though it feels like it's this it's
there's something
familiar about the argument and so i do
think there are similar core wounds
the difference being that sometimes the
codependence correction is this
hyperempathy almost
to an unhealthy level where they're
being empathic to the point where
they're throwing themselves under the
bus
it also feels like
and i don't know i don't know why we
know more about narcissism than
codependency necessarily but one thing
does seem to be true is that an a
codependent seems to be able to say
i have codependency issues correct and a
narcissist
doesn't have the ability to say oh gosh
i'm a narcissist so
why can't they why is it this invisible
dark passenger
with them so there you speak to a huge
difference between people who have these
high conflict personality styles like
narcissism
and people who don't so when people have
the word is
antagonism so when people have these
antagonistic personality styles like
narcissism
one of the things that they don't have
is a self-reflective capacity and
self-reflective capacity is
how to be able to think about how is my
behavior
affecting other people how how do my
words affect other people
so you stop before you speak right so
you don't just start screaming in the
middle of a room or you don't wake
someone up in the middle of the night
and start yelling at them there's
there's no self-reflective capacity
so as a result there's very little
ability and it's a
big piece of empathy to reflect on how
you affect other people
for a narcissistic person to be
vulnerable enough to say
ah you know i'm i'm this i'm i'm
i have this wound or i have this
insecurity that
is very shame activating for them they
feel all the shame who wants to feel
shame
so it's better to walk around and say
hey i'm superman and so then you get to
keep all that at bay
a person who may be again was we're
using this term you know codependent
a person who may be that or more have
more dependency needs as it were
is a person who again who might almost
be too self-effacing
too willing to own up to things that you
know that to
what the word i would use is pathologize
themselves to view them as sort of the
the person with the problem and the
challenge becomes this is that for
people who may be traditionally termed
codependent
they have a real likelihood of engaging
in self-blame everything's their fault
when you make everything your fault it's
actually a luxurious position in a way
it's very very unhealthy very unhealthy
because it's not good for the person
and it makes them feel as though they're
a bad person i'm responsible i'm why
this person is doing this right
when i say luxurious what i mean by that
is this person who feels
so out of control in this relationship
can get some level of control saying if
this is my fault then i can fix
it right and so by taking away
self-blame from a person saying this is
not your fault
in a way that's almost more terrifying
because if it's not my fault
and it's their issue and that can't be
fixed
now what the heck am i supposed to do
what am i doing right so the bottom's
been taken out i still find it
fascinating that they can't see it seems
like
it just seems like one of those things
that i mean have you actually
seen many narcissists say i'm a
narcissist
so perhaps it's a good time to talk
about the forms of narcissism because
you know when i looked into this and
when i started going oh my god
um again it was like a lifeline i'd
watch a video of yours or something on
narcissism and i'd
feel like okay it's not real it's not
real so maybe explaining what a
narcissist is
and then the types of narcissism because
um
you know there's a very big difference
the way that a covert versus an overt
narcissist
appears now the damage is
probably very similar but the um on the
surface they're very different
and um so the covert narcissist
which is my experience is super
challenging like very challenging
so so what is a narcissist and then what
are the types of narcissists
so narcissistic or narcissism or
narcissistic personalities are
characterized by
inconsistent or generally absent empathy
entitlement grandiosity arrogance
superficiality egocentricity being very
selfish
chronically seeking validation and
admiration
a need for a lot of control over a
situation
a hypersensitivity to criticism
difficulty regulating emotion especially
when they're frustrated
or disappointed real challenges with
intimacy in a close relationship
they they're not their their ability to
have sort of the back and forth of a
relationship
is constrained by their need for um for
their
own needs to be met so in other words
they almost view other people as
conveniences
to meet their needs and they're not able
to sort of do the back and forth and
make the sacrifices
required by a relationship when they set
goals they tend to set goals in the
basis of what they think the world would
like
rather than what's meaningful to them
and their capacity for empathy is really
challenged because they're constantly
sort of monitoring their environment for
threats
that's narcissism okay the challenge
with narcissism is there's a lot
of subtypes of narcissism and they don't
all sort of look exactly the same
traditionally most of us think of the
grandiose what you're calling the overt
narcissist
and grandiose narcissism is it's sort of
the the sort of
big extroverted attention seeking look
at me i'm so great i'm at the center of
the party
i'm the coolest i'm the best you know
constantly looking for the social media
followers and likes and
that's that's that person another form
of narcissism and a lot of researchers
believe that
overt or grandiose narcissism and covert
narcissism aren't necessarily always two
separate people
but they're two faces of the same coin
covert narcissism is also called
vulnerable narcissism and it's
characterized by all the stuff i talked
about
but the way it shows is in a much more
passive aggressive
victimized way so instead of just being
in your face
you know uh you're so stupid it's more
like oh god everything comes so easy to
you someone like me who actually does
the work
nothing happens for me but you just show
up and you get money like
ah must be so nice to live in your
little world and so i'm like i think i
was just
insulted but i think at the same time i
also feel sorry for you so i'm not sure
what to feel right now
and they're masterful at that maybe not
intentionally so
when people are with covert narcissistic
people
they're actually exhausted by the
passive aggression they wonder why
they ruin every party they're brought to
but they also feel sorry for them
and they often think of the covert
narcissist as being anxious or depressed
more than they think of them as being
narcissistic because they're not the
life of the party quite the opposite
they're kind of the sad
hang dog person in the corner of the
party who's angry at everybody
and always looks like they're on the
verge of getting into a bar fight that's
your covert narcissist
now the communal narcissist is a whole
different animal
the communal narcissist is the
narcissist who gets their supply
by ostensibly doing nice things for
other people
they give people money they do
charitable stuff
look at me i'm rescuing an elephant i'm
doing this i'm doing that
but they want to be admired for it and
they get their admiration by doing nice
things for other people and they get
angry at people
if they don't feel like they're getting
enough admiration for it
so everybody thinks they're a saint but
the people who maybe work with them
or are in relationships with them say oh
my gosh everyone's telling me i'm so
lucky because they're so
helpful but they're such a mean person
there are malignant narcissists who
almost feel psychopathic they're very
exploitative
they're very manipulative they can be um
very callous very cold um they
almost feel dangerous uh they have all
the stuff of the grandiose narcissist
but with a much more
like machiavellian like they know how to
work a room they know how to work a
system
these are people who often get to the
top of organizations they're not quite
psychopaths which is sort of an
entirely different kind of a thing out
there but they almost have that feel
then there are the self-righteous
narcissists who are super moral
and they're like i they they almost feel
really loyal like they they'll they're
sort of almost feel right or die but
they're not really because everything's
about how moral and great they are
there's a right way to do things and
there's a wrong way to do things and
they're
very contemptuous of other people they
almost feel sort of
snobby and they're very judgy and so
people find them like what is what is
this like this person is not very nice
so
you can see then that these subtypes
mean that
people will say but they rescue all
these elephants i'm like
but they have no empathy i mean empathy
for elephants is great but you got to be
empathic with everyone
not just people who are giving you
supply or notoriety
so at the core of it it ends up being is
there a core to all of these
that that that insecurity the insecurity
that has to be managed with all of this
grandiose grandiosity entitlement
things that protect them and get them
narcissistic supply
so it's as though there are little empty
balloons that need to be filled up all
the time
by people telling them that they're
great
the way i look at it is like the the the
little child that wasn't
loved the way that they wanted to be
loved or needed to be loved
ends up being something they have to
hide for the rest of their life because
they realize that no
they they didn't get what they wanted
with that per with that version
so that version stays hidden and then
it's this facade this mask that they put
out to the world and so anything that
gets close to like seeing
like behind the behind the curtain or
that little inner child
tends to get uh it's like met with like
it's like a sword it's a bar fight it's
whatever it's it's something to
protect themselves from you seeing that
inner child because they're
essentially were told or believed to be
uh believed that that that version of
them was not lovable
correct that's exactly right and so
there's a lot of shame activation around
the fact that they weren't
lovable and so they do really they do
really unhealthy things to be loved
which is why we see a
decent amount of correlation between
narcissism and addiction
if it's not a person who's going to love
them it's the drugs that's going to love
them that you'll see them go through a
series of partners you'll see them cheat
on partners
it's like it's never enough and so that
never enoughness
is that feeding that so they feel like
they're enough and like you said there
is this real
interesting association between the
people who sometimes get stuck in these
relationships who feel like they're not
enough
and ironically the narcissist feels like
they're not enough but the narcissistic
person is
never going to admit to that how dare
you tell me that
what do you think you are a shrink like
you get a lot of that pushback so
that whole explanation you gave danica
which is so loving and warm
a lot of people will do that with their
narcissistic partner i see your inner
child i want to love it and they will
become
enraged that you did that kind of
interpretation
and people will say i don't get this i
see them i want to love them
i said this is this is not your not on
your time like they need to go through
therapy
and see what they're able to do and
they're going to have to learn that
their reactions matter and
guess what i understand their inner
child is hurt but this is a 40 year if
you as a 40 year old adult or 30 year
old adult
you're not three you got to grow up
people go through stuff and you got to
get to the other side
do you find that they are are they they
do they tend to be stuck
like in what ways like i feel as though
uh an indicator possibly of the sort of
original wound
is the reaction like how do they react
do they react like a five-year-old do
they react like a 12-year-old
and that that can maybe kind of pull a
little indication as to when
when the wounds happen but um is that
uh is that is that the case like can you
can you start to identify
that through their reactions i think
that whether you'd be able to pin the
actual moment of the wound because
so much of it developmentally tends to
start at an early age you might see
worsening of some of those experiences
like for example some of the more shame
inducing experiences
people may have stronger memories of
those into like for example
at the end of elementary school into
middle school high school like you have
just more
better formed memories but a lot of the
stuff may have happened
when they were younger things they
witnessed maybe couldn't even put words
to
but what you the like you said the
stuckness or the stuntedness
is very much a part of the narcissistic
personality style
they're very much caught in an earlier
developmental phase so they react like a
child that's why they throw tantrums
you know they literally throw tantrums
like a child would
and so you know one would argue probably
a narcissistic person psychologically
more often than not it's probably stuck
somewhere between two and six
is my guess and then you know and then
you will see sort of adolescent
behavior in narcissistic people like
they're still carrying on like they're
16 when they're 50
and you know but it's still they're
throwing the tantrums of a four-year-old
and it's as though
that it developmentally they're stuck
because what is the work of being an
adult it's about holding space for
others
at times holding back our reactions and
people with antagonistic personality
styles like narcissism
are very reactive it's that
dysregulation i was talking about
if they get frustrated if they get
disappointed if they feel people aren't
noticing them enough
then they completely you know they lose
the plot and they start you know yelling
and screaming
because they're not that to them is
intolerable because they're not able to
be in touch with someone else who knows
they have a core boon saying i can see
someone's talking over me i'm feeling
really uncomfortable this is reminding
me of childhood
i've got to still find a new way to
respond and in my therapeutic work with
narcissistic clients
the work is largely focused on you got
to stop
wait and respond and i mean and i would
say still 70
of the time they get it wrong before
they were getting it wrong 90 of the
time
so we've made a little bit of progress
but depending on how high pressure the
situation is
they will always react and they'll say
can't the people know i didn't really
mean it i just had to get it out and i
said
no they can't that would be like me
punching you in the face and saying
i just had to get that out i didn't mean
it but your face still hurts
right okay well what are let's talk
about the kinds of abuse because i think
these are fascinating and to me
this was these examples were my
sort of uh where the resonance was where
i was like oh my god yeah that happened
to me things like
you know stonewalling like silent
treatments
or um you know gaslighting
um all forms of manipulation crazy
making
like that to me feels like the most
obvious one is where you just go i
i you feel like you're going crazy um
so i'd love for you to kind of go into
this and
hopefully um tap into maybe
something that someone's hearing and and
can go you know like
so let's start with your most basic
example there which is the gas lighting
right
to have your reality denied gaslighting
isn't something that happens once and
you're all in right it's a grooming
process it happens over time
and it requires you to be in a
relationship that's characterized by
trust or some level of authority or
expertise and a new relationship's an
interesting example of that because if
you're attracted to
various elements of the person how they
look and who they are and you really see
that there's a possibility for a
relationship
you want to trust them and when you want
to where you already trust someone
and they start gaslighting you you don't
go right to they're gaslighting me
use the first thing most people do when
they're gaslighted is doubt themselves
like
maybe they're right maybe i am being too
sensitive or maybe i did read that
situation wrong or
maybe i didn't put the keys there or
maybe that didn't happen or maybe
they weren't being inappropriate with
that person and that happens
so it's not happening once or twice it's
happening dozens and then hundreds of
times
when a person's gaslighted they lose a
lot of their power in a situation
because they're spending so much time
saying huh what
and you start thinking like maybe my
memory is going maybe i need to see a
doctor
maybe i'm the one with the mental
illness maybe i'm the narcissist
you people go there now all of your time
is sort of almost trying to get back
your get your footing back
the gas lighter is controlling you more
and more and more
really insidious process and then before
you know it
what the gaslighter does it's an
interesting trick
let's say a person finds their voice and
it's like okay i've got this figured out
i watched one of dr romney's videos i
read something on gaslighting i got this
and you say something like you know what
like i
don't like how you're talking to me or
this i'm not comfortable with this you
know what the gaslighter will say
maybe you're not feeling this
relationship that more i get it like
we've been drifting apart
and they start threatening leaving they
play into a fear that ironically even
though narcissistic people and
gaslighters don't like abandonment
they know it's the ultimate weapon and
now you're into the relationship six
nine
12 months maybe if it's new and you say
i don't want this to break
up i wanted us to have a talk and so
you're silenced once again
because you feel like if i push this
conversation too much they're gonna feel
like i'm pushing back on the
relationship
and they're criticized and so maybe
they're gonna want out so
maybe i am making too big a deal out of
this and you start gaslighting yourself
and then before long the person is
almost just living in the gaslighted
universe
they may give up on goals aspirations
they may talk to people less they may
give up friendships
they may give up all kinds of things in
their life to
live in the universe that the gaslighter
created and so
now they're though to the world it looks
like the two of you are exactly on the
same page
you're not on the same page you're
almost like a cult member now you've
been totally brainwashed
and you're going along with the program
because otherwise you lose the
relationship which in my estimation
would have been the best outcome
but a lot of people aren't ready for
that that's the process
yeah this is that's the sort of like
what i would describe
in my experience was the destabilization
i think that's the destabilization where
you just kind of feel like you're on
your back heels and you're just like oh
you're just trying to hang on like you
don't
quite understand what's going on you're
confused you know
and yeah and that's that's a that's a
destabilizing situation
so um let's talk about um like
stonewalling or silent trees right then
so the silent treatment is a very
popular tool of people in narcissistic
relationships
because it is very manipulative right
to give someone the silent treatment is
very it's very
punitive because you are literally feel
like you're now living in an alternative
universe there's two of you in the
kitchen
and they're not saying a word to you
you're passing like chips in the night
you're standing next to each other
brushing your teeth
they're saying nothing to you this
doesn't just happen in intimate
relationships it can happen in families
you may go to a family gathering and
people there's one person just
literally they'll say hey can you pass
the butter and you're the one next to
the butter
and and people will all be looking and
yeah someone's reaching over to
the butter because they won't talk to
you so it is very punitive
now think about what the silent
treatment ends up getting you them
though
what does it get them you end up
breaking and often say i'm sorry
and they get an apology usually for
something you didn't do wrong
and they hold the power so one could
even argue the silent treatment is sort
of like a satellite of gaslighting
but it's extremely unhealthy it's very
different for a person to say listen
i can feel the steam coming up in me i'm
gonna go take a walk
i'm gonna go clear my head i'm gonna go
do what i need to do but then you come
back and talk to the person
the silent treatment is punishment and
it's a manipulation
and that's a common common tool
something you're calling stonewalling
it's similar to the silent treatment but
it's a little bit of a variation on a
theme
stonewalling is i'm not going to talk
about this anymore
we're not doing this again or just
walking out
because what they've said is i'm not
even going to permit this discourse
it's not you know and so now you're
being told you don't get to bring up
parts of your emotional world a
discomfort about something like that's
all
you know no-fly zones so now your
relationship has all these little sort
of marks on it where
you can't go there because we're not
doing this we're not talking about this
that's stonewalling now some people
argue that narcissists stonewall because
a topic is about to bring up their shame
so they just say i'm putting a stop to
this and there are people like john
gottman who
who talks about marriage and has done
probably some of the most comprehensive
research on this
and to him stonewalling is one of sort
of the you know the death knells of a
relationship if you're engaging in
stonewalling you're sort of at that you
know you're really
coming towards the end and then danica
there are other patterns like um baiting
narcissistic people love a fight and so
you're thinking
why do they say things just to get me
worked up i'm like to get you worked up
they do it's so it's like it's their it
would be like their narcissistic supply
i feel like the drama the chaos the
anger the fear the sadness that comes
out of you is their supply
like once that once there's no more
reaction anymore
they aren't getting supply it's like
they just need energy
they not only need but they need energy
but they also need this which is
superiority
so let's say you generally well put
together they bait you and you're like
and you take the bait now you're like
you're screaming and yelling
and now the narcissist actually calms
down almost instantly your madness
completely calms them down it's like a
tranquilizer for them and they're like
goodness my isn't somebody getting a
little worked up you need to you look
crazy you need to calm down
and that's gaslighting because now
you've been painted as this thing you're
not
but you have literally been baited so
it's about training yourself to not take
the bait
oh my god yeah oh yeah i can remember
being in situations
like you know having a reaction and
going oh no i'm not you know oh well i'm
not gonna react and that's like
you know even then kind of being mini
manipulated or gaslit in a second
in a moment going like well why'd you
react and i'm like well
because if i i mean it's natural
instinct but also
you know if i didn't you just go further
i think that feels like also really one
of the hard things too about narcissism
is that
i mean is there seems like there's kind
of
no there's barely any limit to how far
they'll go
to get some reaction out of you and
they'll do they do
you know it's self-sabotage they kind of
know they're doing it too
they because they push the limits
because they want the reaction because
they need the reaction
right the reaction helps them feel
superior or like i said it helps them
it feels like a relationship to them and
for a person who is sort of trauma
bonded or even the term using
codependent in a relationship
the chaos feels familiar to them too so
everyone's sort of going into chaos and
i try to explain to people the chaos has
no place in a relationship
and people say and they've been very
frank with me in therapy
people say gosh without the chaos it
doesn't feel like it doesn't feel like
love and i said that's an
old message you got we're gonna have to
break that down people say i'll feel
bored
if you know and i'll say boris it's not
about being bored i think that's the
wrong word
i think that your core wounds are no
longer being activated
and you confuse that with love so we
have to sort of change the whole script
i want to talk a little bit about
because this is where i feel like the
real
true depth of confusion comes in and
that's through breadcrumbing
and you know there'll be moments where
you're like oh they're you know like wow
yeah and then it'll be so
bad and then so whoa and then so bad
like
you know you just live for like the
moments where something good will happen
or there's something nice will be said
or eye contact will be made or some
level of a meaningful conversation
or something like that and you know
sometimes it's not always sometimes it's
more superficial but you know it still
has some level of feeling
like attention or something so
breadcrumbing is i feel like
you know sort of the ongoing
dynamic used to keep it to keep things
going
so breadcrumbing is so interesting right
because what to me also a big part of
breadcrumbing is that a person learns to
get by on less and less and less in the
relationship
like they came home for dinner i'm like
is this a big winning moment in your
relationship okay you know and so
it's the um they wrapped my christmas
present or something like something
so small and they they will talk it up
the person in this narcissistic
relationship will talk it up to other
people
you won't believe it like he came home
for dinner tonight or
and people are like they really set a
low bar and that's what breadcrumbing is
the bar gets that lower and lower and
whatever breadcrumbs are given become
the basis of the justification to stay
in the relationship
the the other dynamic you're describing
danica is more of the jekyll high
dynamic which is you've got this person
and this is where
narcissism is such a tricky personality
style
because it's something i call alignment
the narcissistic person's having a good
day
and you're aligned with that like you're
having a good enough day too
it feels like you feel like you're in
something that almost feels like a fairy
tale
like they're so engaging so smart
you know charismatic they really are so
you're like oh my god this feels so good
but then when that alignment isn't met
let's say they had a bad day at work or
someone said something they didn't like
or someone made a post on their social
media they didn't like whatever little
thing
sets them off you might be thinking oh
we had a good morning so of course we're
gonna have a good afternoon
and now you're looking at utter darkness
and then what do people do
they blame themselves what did i do what
did i do there's no fixing it
because their wound got activated their
shame got activated
and at those times you you just can't
win and i think that
backing and forthing between them are
actually
sort of being on point because their
needs are being met
and then the moments when they're not
that they the rage and everything and
the disappointment escalates
people get confused by that and the
question is even if you understand it
how long can you stick into something
like that how long can you it's like
living in a place where
you go from 90 degrees to a blizzard in
half an hour it's hard to dress for the
weather
so another one that comes up every now
and again is like word salad
that's another descriptor tell people
with that
so word salad is something when people
experience they're like what just
happened
and it's not psychotic it's crazy right
i kind of lop that into the crazy maze
yes
word salad is part of crazy making where
you get done and you're like i have no
freaking idea like what are we talking
about i don't even know what just
happened why how is this my fault now
right so word salad is it's like when
you think of the various vegetables in
word salad they're things like diversion
moving the goal posts deflection blame
shifting all of that gets thrown
together
word salad is actually a very clever
gambit and it also reflects their
inability to regulate their emotions so
they get really worked up
and so you might bring up a point
whatever that point may be
you're heard about something or i
thought we had made a plan that
we were going to go to this place by
this time something very simple
by the time it's done they'll say oh
here you are asking me things again
you're always asking me things and do
you remember that time 10 years ago when
you asked me that thing
and i did it i did everything on time
and you tell me i don't and then you
spread things rumors
and you're like what are we you're right
what are we talking about i just wanted
to tell you if we don't go to this
meeting today we're not going to get it
again for a month
and you're now talking about things that
happened 10 years ago on a vacation
that word salad speaks to the
dysregulation but also the
incapacity for a narcissistic person to
take responsibility
because if they take responsibility the
shame gets activated
and so i'm not perfect right and so it's
easier to deflect the blame on to you
and so or talk about things that
happened in the past
to create some sort of bizarre false
argument about
why they're right or you've done them
wrong and it confuses the heck out of
people
because then you if you don't know
what's word salad you start falling into
the salad too you're like
wait a minute 10 years ago when we were
on that trip and now you're talking
about the trip 10 years ago
that has no relevance to what's
happening which is why danica
i use this this technique i use with i
talk about it all over the place is
this technique called the deep technique
and i tell people if you're in a
relationship with the narcissist
deep stands for don't defend don't
engage
don't explain and don't personalize
so i say when a narcissist is kind of
going at you go you have to think go
deep okay i'm not going to defend myself
i'm not going to explain myself i am not
engaging this and i'm not personalizing
this
this is on them and what it allows you
to do is like is you're thinking about
it because if you defend yourself
you're going to go right down the rabbit
hole with them
same with explaining and even any form
of engaging
so you've and a lot of people say well
maybe yeah 10 years ago i
it's not relevant we're not talking
about 10 years ago
this is them lashing out at you
inappropriately and just not
communicating
directly and understand that this is
their stuff
don't make it yours the crazy making the
stuff that doesn't make sense right
because when it doesn't make sense
i always say now i'm like if something
doesn't make sense i don't have enough
information
and so like what it means to me in those
situations it's like i don't know the
core
room wound like i don't necessarily know
what happened like why is this reaction
coming out why is there
confusion at all like why can't this be
clear
right and but the challenge becomes
let's say you do know the court wound
okay
it is how many times you want to be on
this carousel as it goes around so you
understand the core wound
you know they're going to keep getting
worked up every time this happens so
if this was a three-year-old child you'd
be using some combination of
time out and consequences and all the
things we do to shape a child's behavior
and yet this is an adult so that's not
going to work so i think that the real
tricky bit is when we have the core
wound conversation
and as people are listening to this i'm
concerned people will sometimes say okay
i'm going to figure out my narcissistic
person's core wound
and no that's you're not their shrink
they may have one and this is why
i am not a fan of people saying going up
to narcissistic people and calling them
names i don't want anyone to call anyone
names
but i want people to do is set
boundaries and say i'm not doing this
anymore this isn't good for me
frankly it's not good for you but you
don't seem to care about that
but i think that when people really try
to do that kind of work where i'm going
to figure out what's up with this person
i say to them you need to get your house
in order you need to figure out why you
feel the need to rescue other people
first
and once you get your stuff in order you
want to go and do core wound stuff with
them that's on you
but you don't get to do that kind of
exploratory work with this narcissistic
person in your life
and making you know and cutting all this
slack until you
do your own work and understand you are
worthy of boundaries
you are worthy of better treatment
because i think then people still fall
into that
into that really really problematic
chasm of i am going to rescue this
person
i've got this figured out i know how to
do this i don't know how to do this and
i've been doing this for 25 years
so trust you me you're not going to come
up with this and most people aren't
and they may end up wasting another 10
years in fact they'll get bad advice
saying well you know he had a rough
childhood
and if you could just okay and they just
and ten years of their lives have now
gone
yeah i want to talk about boundaries but
one last thing i want to ask about and
then
ask if there's anything else from the
sort of like
the ways that were that the treatment um
the forms of abuse
uh but there's one that i have a
curiosity about that was a is like
just a feeling is
do since narcissistic
personality disorder narcissists in all
forms they don't have the empathy and
they can't feel
i wonder do they learn from learn how to
act in situations
based on mirroring people
and also even from movies and things
like that is that how they learn
behavior
yeah so they remember and i actually
don't know that i agree that they don't
feel they
feel they feel actually really deeply
they just don't care about your feelings
so they're feeling that's why you're
healing all this yelling and screaming
and banging around and all that's all
feeling
they just don't care about your feelings
so they're not like people who would be
more like what we call excusoid
personality styles
where there's absolutely no emotional
like they're completely restricted
there's emotion here it's just a lack of
interest in other people's emotions
because theirs is so overwhelming
remember what the goal of the
narcissistic person is in a relationship
to get supply
right so if they want someone supplied
they meet someone new that they want to
date or they're interested or want to
flirt with they have a business
associate or
investor they want to win over um
they're when they
want something from someone or they want
something to look a certain way
they know what to do and this is what
upsets and angers people in these
relationships you're like
they know what to do i'm watching them
do it with someone else
why can't they do it with me i'm like
because they don't want your supply they
want their supply
and so they're not going to do it you
know i'm like i'm not going to give
someone a dollar for something i don't
want to buy
but i'm going to give it to someone else
when i want to buy it that's what that's
how they are with supply and so
yes they know what to do this idea of
mirroring though nails it because it's
as though
they know what like the pleases and the
thank yous and the listening and the aha
or that sounds hard
it's it's like putting on a show or
putting on a play and it's actually
falls into something we call
cognitive empathy cognitive empathy is
sort of the
sort of like splendor to sugar kind of
thing it's not the real thing
and it doesn't feel or tastes as good
and so it's more of the
um it's the it's the it's the
knowing what empathy is knowing like i'm
supposed to listen to this person and
i'm supposed to tell them i feel bad and
i'm
or i'm supposed to like really tell them
they're great i'm supposed to
right and so and in fact ironically
people are narcissistic will often cry
at movies but yet then you'll be in real
life with them you're like
this is like real pain six inches from
you and you're talking about a random
person in a movie
because when when emotion is in their
space
they're threatened by it because they
don't feel like they can manage it
but when it's a story remember all they
do have a lot of emotion in them
that's a safer place to express it and
people misread that oh they cried at the
movie
what a sweet emotional person i'm like
no
it's cognitive empathy booby prize uh
explain
i think this is also fascinating because
there's such that initial part
in a relationship with the narcissist
that um
probably in almost anyone but definitely
more of a romantic one where
uh you know the love bombing and so you
know this love bombing devalued discard
hoover sort of loop um i think this
would be fascinating for people to
understand but especially that love
bombing
stuff so the love bombing is the it's a
grandiose show
often grandiose but not always and i'll
explain that not always but
it's it's a it's this intense attention
the narcissist will pay in the early
part of a relationship
frequent texting never met anyone like
this i feel a magical connection to you
they use this grandiose non-specific
language
you're sort of swept away can feel very
romantic if they've got the means they
may send you flowers or gifts or
come up with elaborate experiences what
it's all doing in a way
it's blinding a person to the red flags
all of this excitement's happening you
may be missing sort of that
they sometimes are a little distracted
on their phone or they're still doing
some shady stuff or
they don't really showed up lately they
showed up late or they're sort of rude
to a person who ballet parked their car
or something like that that you'll say
oh well no no i'm overthinking it or
maybe i'm the one who's afraid of
commitment i finally found someone who's
paying attention to me
and now i'm trying to find red flags
there's something wrong with me
and whereas i'm thinking again red flags
a red flag what's interesting is that
the other thing that can happen during
love bombing
is there can be this really intense of
like tell me your deepest
fear and they t you know why they're
taking all that
they're putting it in a backpack so they
can use it against you
and that you think you're entering this
deep intimate sense of someone
and you're basically handing them the
knives they're going to use to stab you
with
and then when you ask for their deepest
it's nothing you get nothing it's
nothing or they give you a falsehood
because then it won't hurt them if you
did actually attempt to hit them back
so another way love bombing can happen
is they will present a very overly
victimized story of their lives like
my life has been so hard my life has
been so tough and
rescuers will say oh my gosh you need a
place to live come over with me or you
need a car like i don't always use my
car
and before you know it there's people
who are actually now turning around and
covert narcissists tend to play that
game a little bit more
very victimized love bombing and people
feel like
i want to rescue them and they really do
well with people who are hyper empaths
so that's the love bombing phase that
can last
anywhere usually for six weeks to three
months i've heard people telling me it's
lasted for five years i've heard it
lasting for six to twelve months but
usually somewhere in neighborhood maybe
three to four months is about average
because that's about all they can keep
it up for then
once they and a lot of people even be
resistant and say like oh they're so
into me i can
you know i can even like i could be
chilling or you know i don't i can play
this game with them
but then what will happen is they'll
start losing a little steam you're like
okay i'm into you and you move things
too fast narcissistic relationships
more often than not move too fast people
move in too fast they get engaged too
fast they talk about marriage too fast
they travel together too fast they move
to another city too fast
too fast and why because the narcissist
needs to get you to the point where they
can
devalue you once you agree to them they
have
believe it or not such low self-esteem
like if you want to be with me you can't
be all that is actually probably what's
happening deep inside of them
but what they have is they have you
where they need you your narcissistic
supply starting to get a little bit
stale
because you're not something they need
to fight for you're not feeding their
ego
so now they may have a roving eye they
may be much more distractible
they may be much more likely to pull out
your point out your flaws
but at this point a person still feels
very much in love now they're justifying
then we go to the discard now the
devalue phase can last for years to be
honest oh yeah
that's all those forms of abuse years
and years gas lighting
now the discard may or may not be a
breakup a lot of people think does this
card mean they move out no
not necessarily discard may mean they go
and have an affair
and they're very much out of the
relationship the discard may mean that
really they've become so neglectful they
don't even know you're alive like they
just don't care they don't care about
anything about you
the discard may be you wanting to leave
the relationship ironically
because you've had it but it's either a
relationship rupture
or it's you have been literally replaced
and you're sitting there thinking like
okay let's go to counseling since you're
having your tenth affair kind of thing
and so that's discard at the discard
phase either they've left
you've left or there's been a split
there's
there's
been a split well now the narcissistic
person who doesn't like abandonment
and doesn't like not being in control
now you can start the hoovering process
which maybe the narcissist even went and
had an affair or even found a new
relationship
well you know that's not going to last
forever or they don't like the idea that
you're moving on with your life
so you'll get that late night text maybe
i'm just thinking about you
or miss you or you'll get what i always
call the anniversary date hoover
maybe it is your anniversary maybe it's
a birthday christmas thanksgiving some
other holiday
and they'll use that of thinking about
you on new year's eve they'll use those
as entry points and those can often be
lonely times for people
that then starts to hoover back in and
then the whole cycle starts again now
not everybody's hoovered and some people
out there think
i wasn't hoovered was i not even good
enough to be hoovered i'm like
count yourself amongst the lucky be glad
sometimes the hoover happens five and
ten years later
where hopefully a person sort of moved
on and healed
but um but that's the cycle and so
you know i always say to people if you
really want to have like a fling with a
narcissist it's like eating the top off
a cupcake go for it just get out in six
weeks
you know and then you're out before
there's been any damage and maybe you
had a good time
but the longer you're in the more the
narcissistic person frankly is going to
view that they need to control you
so if you try to leave during the love
bombing phase
you're going to be either heavily
hoovered
or they're going to do a smear campaign
on you and they're going to speak
disparagingly of you on social media to
maybe mutual people you know
so there's really no winning in this so
in all seriousness you don't even need
the top of the cupcake the minute you
see the red flags
get out while the getting's good you
reminded me of
sort of the smear campaign and the
flying monkeys
um so i think those are also important
to understand for people because they'll
always be a cycle
with these people whether they're a
family member or a friend or whatever
and so i think it's some important
aspects of the dynamic
is just the things that they do
afterwards or
to keep their keep themselves um
you know looking shiny and good and you
looking bad
and they say horrible things about exes
or they say horrible things about
friends or family or whatever it is um
and um and also just sort of that um
flying monkey sort of
dynamic where there's people that have
their back they kind of have these
they have willing soldiers for the
for the narcissistic mission to keep
them keep them happy
yep that's exactly right and that that
whole army of flying monkeys and
that that what we call triangulation
this creation of chaos
turning people against each other they
are masterful at that
and so and a lot of people came from
families like this too so it's easy to
fall back right back into that
triangulation swamp when it happens to
you again
and people are hurt they'll say i can't
believe my friends fell for this
i'm like i hate to tell you it's a time
to clean house because if your friend
who knew you
is able to fall for the narcissist
machinations this person didn't have
your back
and while it's painful to mount up that
many losses at the same time
i view it as cleaning house you know i
think that the
the the hardest thing after after
the aftermath is the is the trauma bond
it's the it's it's the it's
it's almost like it's death by a
thousand knives kind of a life
instead of it being just one thing to
get over it's like
so it's death by a thousand knives you
feel kind of like
empty and um your sort of self-worth has
been
sort of brought to an all-time low
um so i think there's the trauma bond um
aspect that feels the hardest to me so
do you have advice for people who are in
this scenario to
cope and and and next steps so the
hardest part of the trauma bond is it's
replaying out cycles from earlier in
life right
that the judge because when a child has
a narcissistic or dysregulated or
difficult or antagonistic parent
the child makes justifications for the
parent because the child has no choice
you can't say
mom dad i'm breaking up with you you
know you got it you got to stick it out
and so the child will justify this must
be my fault maybe if i do this better or
sometimes a child acts out like they get
into trouble but more and often than not
they blame themselves and wonder what
did i do wrong
fast forward into adulthood that same
trauma bonded cycle then
lasts into adulthood the same
justifications they made in childhood
for what was happening at home
now is sort of normative in a
relationship again you keep getting into
the same fights over and over again
you keep justifying the other person's
behavior there's a lot of self-blame
this has got to be my fault
all of those are very characteristic of
the trauma bond and then basically the
core of the trauma bond is
love means rejection love means abuse
this is love because this is what love
feels like
what you learned as a kid and then as
the relationship is slipping away
instead of a person saying oh there's a
grade i've dodged a bullet like i got to
get out of here it's
how do i fight for this how do i make
this work
because it's the the trauma bond is
again rejection is love so i want to
keep love and so
how do i work harder and that idea of
i'm going to pedal faster in a
relationship
is very much the trauma bonded space so
in order to get out of it
part of it is to understand this idea of
how a person justifies i often have
people make a list literally sit down
and make a list say tell them i want you
to write down every terrible thing that
happened in this relationship
they're like geeks i said i don't care
how long it takes and it might pop and
make you know keep it on a place you
know maybe it's easily accessible a
phone or whatever journal you always
have
and then when you start feeling like you
want to justify i want you to go back to
that list
and most people say god seeing it all in
one place that's a lot
i said then i want you to make another
list i want you to make a list of
everything and every one you gave up on
for this relationship
the baby showers you missed the nights
out with your friends
the old friends who were maybe of a that
were making your partner jealous
the career opportunities you might have
turned down dropping out of school make
a list of all that so you can see how
much you
gave up and really think about that and
what the ramifications are
and then the other thing i tell people
is when you leave a narcissistic
relationship and i'd be some people
think this is extreme guidance but i
really hold to it
i want people to take 12 months off 12
months out of relationships i think you
need a period of time
everyone needs a period of time where
these narcissistic relationships through
the gaslighting
so infuse us with the reality of another
person we need to get reacquainted with
ours or for some people
get acquainted with it for the first
time keep that list
very close at hand when you say i'm so
lonely on a friday
open it up and recognize your average
friday night consisted of you being
criticized or them showing up three
hours late or then making fun of what
you wanted to do
or watch or how you look and all of a
sudden that friday night in your jammies
watching tv by yourself
feels a little bit more peaceful have
that year go through everything in a
year once
develop your interests your stuff so the
next time you meet someone
you're much more clear on who you are
and what you're about and you're sort of
doing that cleanly
yeah i truly believe that's such great
advice and i truly believe that
from my experience is that the only way
that you can really know yourself is to
spend time alone
if you're trying to exist if you're
trying to know your true tendencies your
true personality your true patterns your
true feelings
your true resonant state of energy um
but it's being alone that gives you the
most sight to yourself
because you're like you wake up in the
morning and you're like what am i going
to do today
i could do anything today and that is a
lot different than going to work and
then making dinner and then
you know doing homework and that's not
you and so i think that that time alone
is incredible advice but danica some
people like you said you made a very
important point some people can't get
out of relationships whether for reasons
of culture religion
money um fear whatever their reasons are
i never judge a person's reasons for
having to stay in a difficult
relationship
you can still address the trauma bond
you can do what we call gray rocking
which is being very neutral in your
communications
you can cultivate other social networks
it might be
a support group therapy a community
group you join volunteering
friendships you know colleagues whatever
you have access to
recognize the trauma-bonded person
people who are trauma-bonded view their
relationship
as a one-stop shop they need to be their
partner their friend
their therapist their coach you try to
people are trauma bond to try to be
everything to their partner realize that
you really i mean
figure out why you're staying be very
honest with yourself like
this is my culture and i can't leave
however and or and
this relationship is and i'm being
treated business you know one of the
things too is boundaries are one of
those things where
i feel like i always thought they were
like for someone to do to me
and uh i realized they were for me my
own limit right there's a they're kind
of similar but they're totally different
orientation
and so i i think that having boundaries
is
something you develop also by being
alone because you're like you feel so
good and then when something happens
you're like oh wait no i'm not going to
do that because it makes me feel bad
instead of
saying like i'm not going to let someone
cheat on me it's like no i'm not going
to get to the point where i feel so
confused and question this relationship
so much
is my own threshold right now not for
someone else to do to us
correct um so well then i guess i finish
up with
you know what what if you what if
someone is um
you know if someone is in a relationship
and they are stuck
is there is there any advice for for
this person
is it yeah i would say it is it's
painful advice and it is and i
understand it can sometimes feel like an
inauthentic sort of almost ha
life half lived but i would say you have
to have realistic expectations
it is better to know what you know know
what you're dealing with like it would
be like living in chicago and in
february saying i'm going to go out in a
sundress i'm like good luck with that
okay it's it's chicago it's february you
need a coat
you're in a narcissistic relationship
you need realistic expectations
of what's going to happen so i tell
people you know sort of remember sort of
the good the bad and the indifferent
never take your good news to the
narcissist first always find the people
who can receive your good news
with oh my gosh i'm so happy for you and
in a loving way so when you finally take
it to the narcissist and they kind of
poo poo it
you already got your like you you can
feel good about it
the bad news never take that to the
narcissist first because they're going
to think you're inconveniencing them
they're going to get angry at you try to
figure out other places for problem
solving i have a lot of clients who do
that with me
they will actually bring those the bad
news to me and we'll sort of problem
solve together
and they'll feel more at ease sometimes
they have to tell their partner or their
family member because they do
but they don't feel like they were they
had to deal with the devastation of bad
news and then get sort of hit again if
you will
and then finally the indifferent i said
the indifferent is where the
narcissistic relationship happens
make a list of indifferent topics the
the weather
the freeway traffic the color of the
mailbox across the street can you
believe the neighbors made so much noise
cutting down that tree like
really neutral topics neutral need a
list of them people say well that
doesn't feel really feel like a
relationship i said
i never promised this was going to be a
relationship you're saying you're in a
place you can't leave
and then cultivate those other supports
you know whatever form that looks like
therapy
support groups friendships anything you
can do and in the pandemic we learn to
be creative with that
but find those other spaces so you at
least feel somewhat supported
and some people say i'm in the states
when my kids are 18. that's fine you
know it may be that you can this might
be a strategy for six years 10 years
and then at that point there may be
there may be something else on the other
side of that everyone has different
stories
but what you and it all comes down to
radical acceptance
narcissistic personalities are
incredibly resistant to change and it is
a
unicorn if you think someone's gonna
have a big turn around and one day
become
a warm fuzzy huggy bear who's totally
empathic
you may get someone who goes through
therapy and might be a little more
regulated
may learn to be a little less
contemptuous but when the rubber meets
the road
and they're really stressed and
frustrated you can promise you that
narcissist is going to blow up again
it's just radical acceptance
and then you're less likely to
personalize it great advice
thank you thank you so much thank you
danica it was a real pleasure work
i appreciate it so much it's truly was a
lifeline
when you wrote when i'm when i had those
moments of being reminded oh my god it
just wasn't real
right because it's like it's all just a
facade whether it was the love bombing
or devaluing that's
not real right and i think for people to
recognize it's so universal then you
realize this isn't some strange
black hole only you're stuck in you've
got great company in there
so yeah this is pretty universal so
thank you again it was a real pleasure
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click
on the subscribe button